it was better than every dream I'd ever
had as like a nine-year-old girl
thinking about like her Cinderella
wedding it was just like that on crack
the famously down-to-earth Canadian girl
may have had a dream wedding but she
kept her real on the day I had two Big
Macs and pizza at the wedding I think
there's a picture of me like sitting on
the dance floor eating a Big Mac we had
some delivered at 11:30 and Pizza on
silver platters Us Weekly scored an
exclusive invite to give fans a glimpse
of Italian Robbie's picture-perfect day
but not everything went as planned my
mom forgot my veil in Toronto so when I
went to put on my hair my wedding dress
I was like mom where's the veil and she
goes it's in the box and I opened a box
like yeah it's not and she just sort of
froze and like slumped back onto the
couch and just bawling and I was like
it's okay it's okay I have a planner
we're downtown LA we can find a veil
it's not a big deal we found a veil it
was fine she was horrified but it ended
up in financing we lost a mimosa mimosa
wedding disaster averted
check but unfortunately for the happy
couple weddings don't always lead to
honeymoons when you're both actors right
now the way things are looking our
schedules don't line up till 2018 so no
plan really yep Italia was back in the
oval office the week after the ceremony
though at least the cast and crew kept
the wedding vibes alive in her trailer
and as for having a husband now she's
not quite used to the word husband ha ha
ha